It it's a devastating time and it's hard to do anything,
but be heartbroken over what happened to George Floyd
and his family. You know, the,
one of my hopes that rise out of this protests is that there's like a
set of changes that people demand because the danger is that
all of this energy and heart and spirit and passion
ends up getting channeled, but like no one knows what to do.
So we need to fight for something real and concrete.
It's been a devastating and heartbreaking time in our country every night
where either transfixed by what's happening on streets or
around the country,
or in some cases were on the streets ourselves. I mean, there,
there are curfews that have been
implemented in dozens of cities,
but I saw a report this morning saying that 10,000 people have been arrested in
relation to the protests. And, you know, that's a very,
very small fraction of the folks who've been marching.
So you're looking at hundreds of thousands of people who've been gathering and
protesting around the country.
I went to a vigil here in upstate New York and hundreds of people came out
and we also, what happened to George Floyd,
having his life extinguished before our eyes.
It's like how many people are killed by police every year.
And the sick part is you don't know that it's
unclear how many people die, uh,
in encounters with police or in police custody every year,
because the data's not reported despite the fact that a law was passed that,
uh, asked the department of justice to compile this report.
Um, but they just never have gotten the data because it's dependent upon police
departments submitting.
And so you have 18,000 police departments around the country. Uh,
and the best estimates are that a thousand or
more Americans die in contact with police annually
cities spend hundreds of millions of dollars a year on
settlements for police brutality cases.
New York city alone spends 300 million a year on direct payments
liability, Chicago, 47 million nationwide.
You're looking at about a billion dollars or more annually.
And if you think about what that means, you know,
that only a small fraction of the people that actually would have a legitimate
case can successfully Sue the city and get a settlement.
So you're looking at billions of dollars, uh, easily,
um, in liability.
And the billion dollars I'm talking about is just direct payouts. It's,
doesn't include lawyer's fees, which we know can be massive or insurance,
which we know can be massive. That's just payouts to people.
That's just payouts directly to families.
So looking at it objectively, you'd have to say, okay,
this is a very significant problem. And you know,
it's a significant problem in part,
because of district attorneys bringing suits against police officers who are
accused of misconduct. But if you look at the incentives of the da,
the da works with police officers hand in hand every single day to make cases.
The last thing they want to do is go to war over some police
misconduct. And it's similar for the local mayor. Like the mayor,
his best friend is likely the police chief and the
mayor does not want to go to war with law enforcement in their community,
because there are some of the most powerful constituents in the community.
So you're looking at a massive problem,
the scope of which you don't really even know because we don't have the data.
And we all know if there had not been a video of George Floyd being killed,
it just would have been another unnoticed, um, deaths.
So there's.
Frustration, there's anger, there's fear. Yeah.
It, but to me and Nicole.
Conversations, I've been having,
there's a sense of helplessness as you watch this unfold, you know,
you wake up every morning and you see another horrific instance.
And you're like, what, what can I actually do?
Where's the first place we can start as a society to start
fixing this? Well,
there are studies that have been done as to what we can do to improve please
violence. And, uh, the work that campaigns zero has done,
I find really compelling because it's very, data-driven, uh,
one of the leaders there as a data scientist.
And so they have six recommendations that have been proven to work.
And they're not easy because again,
you're talking about 18,000 police departments.
But one thing that was on the list was federal oversight.
When the department of justice has investigated police departments,
incidents of police brutality have dropped significantly.
And so one thing I've, uh,
championed is that we should have a new George Floyd police misconduct division
of the department of justice that is dedicated to police misconduct issues
around the country. Because if you look at it objectively,
the local law enforcement officials are going to have a very hard time bringing
suits against other law enforcement officials in their vicinity.
If you're a good cop or a da or the mayor,
you are thrilled that there is someone who can come in and
administer and prosecute these matters. That's not you because in your case,
like you're picking a fight with someone who's in your backyard.
But if you have the feds come in,
then they can be objective and hold people accountable.
You've talked about this task force a lot.
So actually it'd be interesting to see how this would work. So theoretically,
you're the da in Minneapolis.
Would you be the one calling this task force to come in or the, the,
this task force seat objectively? And it's like, it's out of your hands.
We make the decision. Like, how does it mechanically? How does this work?
Or how would you want it to work?
The, because of we can all see enormous public pressure.
Like the district attorney has brought charges against the four officers
involved, right?
But in the absence of this kind of situation where it's literally in the
national spotlight, you'd have the independent investigators who,
who act like the FBI,
where they can be called in by local law enforcement,
but they could be called in by local members of the community too.
So why don't you talked about data?
One of the things we've struggled with is there's not.
The data is rough w which is a major problem. And that leads us to number two,
that you need to track complaints,
and you need to keep a database of officers who are fired or disciplined
because right now,
what happens is you can fire a bad cop and then they'll leave that town or a
state, and then go someplace else and then get rehired.
The other piece of this,
or how to deescalate a situation in most of these situations are not inherently.
Right?
So there are a range of situations where you call
someone and you'd prefer that they show up and resolve the situation in a
non-violent way. And so there, there are two elements to this.
One is trying to train police officers to have a continuum of use of force
where deadly force is the absolute, absolute last resort. But the other thing,
which is what I was suggesting is that you could have non police organizations
that are able to respond to emergency calls in Oregon.
They have this crisis assistance helping out on the street organization,
where you have crisis workers and mental health providers who can respond to
incidents involving homelessness, substance abuse, mental health crises.
And in these situations, you don't need someone showing up like saying, Hey,
like who am I here to pull a gun on?
Like a quarter of police shooting victims are mentally ill.
Majority of mentally ill, people are not violent, are not threatening,
but if you're a police officer and you're in that situation, you're like, well,
snap, like the, you know, this person is not listening to anything I'm saying,
you know, halt or I'll I'll shoot. And then the person doesn't halt,
there are a lot of situations where you need help,
but you don't necessarily need police help.
Like you don't think it's like a life or death situation that's going to involve
a firearm.
Is that related to demilitarizing the police?
I know you've had some comments on that too.
And we were talking about one of our colleagues went to protest and he said it
was peaceful. And the cop.
Showed up who were also peaceful, but they were decked out in riot gear.
Everybody got on edge, and then it got wild. Oh,
ride gear is not the half of it. Zack mean there's a Pentagon program, uh,
that actually allows the military to send surplus military equipment to
police and Sheriff's departments.
So you have some of these 18,000 police departments around the country that have
tanks and armored vehicles and grenade launchers,
and a military style hardware.
And studies have shown that when you have this military equipment in place,
you use it. And then if you use it,
you're more likely to wind up with, uh,
deaths resulting from police action.
So this Pentagon program, um,
was discontinued by Barack Obama's administration and then
was reversed by the Trump administration, which is not surprising.
And so we need to reign this in,
and that makes sense from a human perspective as well.
Like it just putting more people on edge. So when I went to a vigil,
police officers were there, but it was 100% peaceful.
What did it have been different if those police officers had those face masks on
a right gear and like Bess and nightsticks,
it would have given a very different energy. And in many cases,
if you're a protestor showing up, like you're agitated, obviously.
And so if there's a police officer there who let's say is wearing a normal
outfit, you can see their face and interact with you like a human.
Then you're more likely to have like a less negative or
violent interaction with them than if they're like a faceless military-style
looking figure. And I think it's true on both sides.
Like I genuinely think if you cover my face with a mask and give me a
Baton, like I'm more likely to be an.
Then if you can see my face and I'm looking at UI to I, right,
I'm really interested. And I'm interested in your thoughts on this, on that,
the community aspect of this.
Like what have you seen there as a good solution that could work?
There've been positive examples of community-based policing,
where police officers regularly volunteer and spend time in
like rec centers and plain clothes where it's not always just rolling up in the
cruiser, like in full uniform. And then you,
you wind up with more trust being developed in both directions.
This episode of yang speaks is brought to you by an outer known.
So I got a couple of things, amount of known,
and I'm a way down where I'm one of them was a pair of jeans because I'm in
Florida and it's super hot. And I put these jeans on and they're fantastic.
So checking all the boxes, I've got shirts, I got button down,
I sweaters and now have jeans, Kelly Slater.
Former pro surfer world champion. You've.
Done it, but this company is awesome. Yeah. The great thing is that, you know,
that these clothes were produced with fair living, wages, factories,
safe working conditions. You can actually wear them with a clear conscience.
We're in a culture now where you have like these disposable clothing.
I cannot believe how cheap a lot of clothes are. When, when you get out there,
these clothes feel different.
They feel better and you feel better.
So go to outerknown.com today and enter my code yang at checkout.
And you'll get 25% off your full price order.
That's outerknown.com O U T E R K N O w
n.com. And use my code yang at checkout for 25% off.
Use yang. It's legit. It's legit discount. You get a quarter off this thing,
do it. It's awesome.
So one thing that has not worked at least, uh, demonstrably,
and this is going to paint.
A lot of people is like implicit bias trainings and empathy trainings.
It's like that. If you go in and you say, Oh, you know,
we're all biased against certain people. Like you may have developed bias too.
And then you try and see whether that changed behavior. Right.
And they haven't been able to demonstrate that it has,
it doesn't mean that it doesn't work. Right.
But they haven't been able to demonstrate that it does work.
And there's similar.
Data on body cameras, right. To know, and body cams.
I love body cams because common sense to me, it's like, look,
if I shoot someone in the dead of night, um, and it says me and that person,
I shot, and there's no footage that will be like, Hey, like person attacked me.
You know? And then you don't know,
at least the footage is like another data point.
I agree. It's definitely, these things are helpful,
but not necessarily affecting the numbers. Right? Like, like, like I don't have.
The illusions that like putting body cams on, on, uh, cops,
like all of a sudden, like, you know, all the problems go away.
But I will say that like, you know,
there have been times when you can refer to the footage and you're like, okay,
like, I have a pretty good sense of what happened here. And, you know,
you saw the opposite of it.
I don't know if you just saw like a police chief was fired in Kentucky and
Louisville because a barbecue restaurant owner was shot
and they didn't have their body cams on. And so like, they looked and said like,
what is going on? Right. So I think that's like a useful standard. It's like,
give people, body cams, say we expect them to be on.
And then if the body cam wasn't on, then you know,
you can start unfortunately like saying like, well,
I think something happened here that shouldn't happen. Particularly if you know,
someone has been shot and killed. Um, so,
so the data is inconclusive on body cams,
but I will say like enthusiastically for body cams,
just give them,
especially cause like we hold people in other contexts that standards, we hold.
Tellers. Yeah. Bank tellers, call center employees, um.
A hotel employees, convenience store. It's like, you know, that,
that stuff's getting recorded and police officers it's literally life or death.
So, you know, if you have the capacity to record, I feel like you,
you definitely should. So the two other things that they've shown work,
make sense. Number one, or number four,
depending on how you're counting is get rid of the language and
police union contracts that limits, uh, officer accountability,
where if an officer is called up on some kind of a complaint or discipline,
these contracts often protect them in various ways.
And if that language gets changed, then complaints go down.
So that's something that's difficult because you have union contracts that are
different across the country, but behavior changes.
If you change those union rules,
then the other is the thing you were saying before about training,
where if police departments have restrictions on
choke holds or certain techniques,
this brings down abuse and fatality rates. Right?
And so this suggests that we should be looking at national standards,
which would go into training.
So you're talking about some of the bureaucracies and protections within police
union contracts. So there was an officer during the Parkland shooting there,
one like school cop hid behind his police car and didn't go inside the building
and that officer was fired.
But then I think it was 15 months later after firing him for neglect of duty.
They were forced to hire him back with back-pay
because firing him was a violation of his rights based on the union
contract under those pretenses. And so what a prime example of like,
if they want to fire somebody, they, they can't. Yeah. I mean,
if you have a police officer who on the scene and could have prevented a
massive loss of life, that was that officer's job in moment of truth.
And if they, you know, shrank from that, then like, if you're a community, like,
do you want that officer.
[Inaudible].
This episode of yang speaks is also brought to you by can't screw it up.
Li I mean, freshly, which is basically idiot, proof cooking.
And essentially the guys, they bring you meals.
And as someone who's screws a lot up his cooking up, I've been loving this.
Cause I tried to make shrimp scampi the other night with my family because I'm
32 years old living at home in quarantine and it shrimper disaster.
So I'm now using freshly way more often.
And I look like a good chef when I do it. Uh, I feel like a good chef,
so I can't screw it up. Yes. You know,
is I can't screw it up in must be a great product.
I'm sure freshly chefs and nutritionists do all the hard work.
All you do is heat for three minutes and that's dinner.
And that like exactly what I need at this point.
So Joanna was one and a half million satisfied customers skip the shopping and
the prepping and the cooking freshly is offering our listeners $40 off
their first two orders at freshly.com/yang.
That's freshly.com/yang for $40 off of food.
That's $40 off some food. Can't screw it up. Li uh,
no it's freshly and you'll thank us. And it's delicious.
I think it's clearly fricking wrong that these cops killed a man
while arresting him when it was completely unnecessary.
And it's extremely wrong that our system hasn't been fixed in decades
of knowing these problems exist. And there's there,
there's things our government needs to do.
And I think people can hold them accountable or try to,
but if you're an average citizen right now, what, what can we do?
What would you recommend individual people do to start writing these wrongs?
It's a devastating time and it's hard to do anything,
but be heartbroken over what happened to George Floyd
and his family, but also what's happening around the country.
We all have to do everything we can to help. So if you want to help first,
just trying to help people in your own life and your own situation,
be the best person you can be. Um, take care of yourself.
Like mental health is a crisis on top of a crisis right now. And you know,
it doesn't do us any good if we're individually not strong or,
or don't have our head on straight in terms of organizations to help,
there are a lot of them. So I don't want to just say like, Oh,
this one or that one,
but some of the organizations that are doing great work in this direction, um,
color of change campaigns,
zero mapping, police violence.org.
One of the organizations I've found working on what you talked about, Andrew,
where you have emergency responders that are not carrying weapons,
responding to certain calls that are ideally non-violent nature.
It's called Whitebird clinic.org. Um, it's based in Oregon,
the David program called cahoots, which stands for crisis assistance,
helping out on the streets. It's mobile crisis intervention,
24 seven programs like that to me, should be scaled around the country.
And then the other thing,
if you're interested in policy and getting new ideas out there at Berkeley,
chief justice,
Earl Warren Institute of law and social policy has done a lot of work on
frankly, community policing and how that works.
So that's the Earl Warren into the law and social policy at the university of
California, Berkeley. You know, the,
one of my hopes that rise onto this protests is that there's like a
set of changes that people demand because the danger is that
all of this energy and heart and spirit and passion
ends up getting channeled, but like no one knows what to do.
So we need to fight for something real and concrete that we can bring to our
communities and George Floyd and his family, and say, look, George,
his life and his death brought about tremendous change.
And here are the changes and we can see them all.
And that this is a positive turning point in our nation's history because
of your brother's sacrifice, your father's sacrifice like the,
the obvious one was like, well, you need to arrest, um,
the officers and now they've all been arrested,
but we can tell that the protest about something much, much bigger, right?
This is the crisis of our time in terms of
racial justice and police brutality.
But there are all of these things that are layered on top of it.
The fact is we've set ourselves up by having what Cornell West
called failure upon failure upon failure for decades,
where you have an economy that hasn't created a decent way of life for millions
of people,
and then a legal system and a police system that has not
protected people's rights, particularly people of color. And, you know,
one thing I don't mind being is like the guy who is still talking about the
economy when no one else is because the economy is still like underpinning all
this stuff. Like we had another 2 million unemployed, you know what I mean?
Yeah,
right now we're adding fuel to the fire because there's this backdrop of
need and desperation, that's rising. We're at depression,
era levels of unemployment. Uh, people are protesting and riding on the streets.
Like the minimum you can do is safeguard people's material wellbeing.
We need to move very fast on universal basic income.
Because right now a quarter of the nation's workforce is out of work.
I've seen surveys between 66 and 80% of Americans agree that we should have cash
relief. During this time,
we're going to be digging out of this economic
catastrophe for years.
And we need to start right now and put people in a position where they feel like
their futures are secure. Right. But that said,
I think people misunderstand you some times,
like you are by no means saying that the money will cure everything.
It will help a lot. But if you give people money,
they're still going to have massive injustice in us, in the police system. Yeah,
of course. Uh, I mean the money is not gonna give George Floyd's family.
Like they're not, it's not going to turn. People's loved ones to them.
[Inaudible].
All right. This episode of yang speaks is brought to you by Skillshare,
which I think is essentially the way we're going to educate in the future.
So if you want to learn anything from Phil in video, graphic design,
or time management or mental health practices,
they have online classes and how to actually tangibly learn these skills on your
own at your own time, and then apply them to your career, your life,
your family, whatever you think is helpful, drawing, writing,
and journaling classes to help you manage stress during this time
interior design, if you're trying to redecorate or rearrange your, your space,
because you've been staring at the same place for weeks on end,
a friend of mine actually founded this company. Uh, and he's a great guy.
And this company, uh, is just what the doctor ordered for many of us,
explore your creativity and get two free months of premium
membership@skillshare.com slash yang.
That's two whole months of unlimited access to thousands of classes for free get
started and joined today by hitting the skillshare.com/yang,
two free months of unlimited access to thousands of classes at
skillshare.com/yang. They got a class here on time management,
which in productivity, which I think is frankly so needed,
but this is a deal guys. You get this stuff for free for two months,
load up on a much content as you can. So skillshare.com.
Flashy.
So I'm going to recap, just make sure we're aligned.
If you're listening to this and you want to help.
I think my best thing to do is call your Congressman or Congresswoman in your
area or your district call your Senator.
And here's the things you should ask for. And I, Andrew,
make sure I get these right one cash relief, universal basic income.
Let's put out the massive unemployment fire and financial scarcity.
That's fueling a lot of desperation in our communities.
Two is federal oversight and a federal task force three is better training
for officers,
which includes community policing and not using choke holds and
nonviolent responses to emergency calls for is better data.
And making sure we track this and we know exactly what we're measuring and what
we're trying to solve for. And then lastly,
five would be loosening up these extremely strict bureaucratic union
contracts that are preventing our institutions from acting.
Those are the five I have. I miss anything are there. There's,
there's the big six demilitarization, ah,
freak in tanks and grenade launchers out of the hands of police departments
around the country that should be serving and protecting and not treating it
like a war zone. Right?
So hopefully this is a helpful way to act for you listening to
this. Um,
hopefully you feel there's there's causes that release or types of organizations
to start looking for to help. We are all about solutions because to me,
what we, the worst outcome is that we have these protests over and over,
and then nothing happens. That's, that's the worst outcome, I believe. And,
or just keep this, this several actions, these Carroll actions keep happening.
Yeah. So w we to make real changes in our society,
and we need to present a vision for what those changes must be,
and then make them real,
keep pressure on our leaders until they become law.
And people will know that George's life and his death
change the course of history in this country for the better.
[Inaudible].